johnny depp parties in london as the
jury reaches a verdict in his defamation
case against ex-wife amber hurd question
the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp answer yes
before that unfolded in court wednesday
johnny partied with tom jones on tuesday
night after performing at the royal
albert hall in london johnny looked
casual and relaxed ahead of his big day
in court sporting a black and white
striped jacket and his signature scarf
hat and sunglasses and get this his ex
kate moss was at the concert to support
him sharon osbourne shared this pic with
her backstage at the venue the outing is
fresh off kate testifying on johnny's
behalf just last week did mr depp push
you in any way down the stairs
no johnny's been spending time singing
in the uk since closing arguments in the
defamation case tuesday's performance
was the second time he jumped on stage
with jeff beck he first made a surprise
appearance at a show over the weekend
johnny depp gives surprise performance
at jeff beck concert
[Music]
cut to wednesday's verdict which was
probably music to johnny's ears do you
find that mr depp has proven by clear
and convincing evidence that ms heard
acted with actual malice answer yes
johnny wasn't in the courtroom for the
reveal a source telling e.t his work
commitments in the uk kept him overseas
meanwhile amber was in court her
spokesperson shaming johnny for not
showing up in a statement to et quote
your presence shows where your
priorities are johnny depp plays guitar
in the uk while amber heard waits for a
verdict in virginia depp is taking his
snickering and lack of seriousness on
tour as against amber heard we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of 10 million dollars
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars depp
originally sued her for 50 million
dollars for making what he believed to
be defamatory statements in a 2018 op-ed
she wrote at the height of the metoo
movement the jury awarded him 10 million
in compensatory damages and an
additional 5 million in punitive damages
the judge knocked that down to just 350
000 in punitive damages though the cap
in virginia meanwhile when it comes to
herd's countersuit against depp the jury
acknowledged she also proved defamation
but to a lesser extent they awarded her
two million dollars